but Hagrid there must be a mistake they  kept us having fun the whole time good  you can help Harry then Hermione made  complete sense to me I've been worrying  about my potions final I have had kidney  stones and a baby I think I'll eat  something for long but I'm defined  obviously we were just kids and we were  all looking forward to mucking about  I feel like being a Weasley is the best  part of being in Harry Potter that bear  is the secret to Our Success you know  when you shouldn't break a director's  writ  I'll fight you it's not easy because it  takes a tremendous amount of patience  with kids I hope there's pudding I would  find life a bit hopeless without Harry  Potter Maybe  doesn't think she's evil how many are  there common question is you look so  different your house will be like your  family it got to a point when it was too  late to catch up